Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
SHANDI SHARED THE PAIN
OF HER TROUBLED
FAMILY RELATIONSHIPS.
Suzannah: YEAH,
SHANDI NEEDS FAMILY.
DOES ANYBODY HUG YOU?
Tyra: WHILE APRIL OUTSHINED
HER ACTING COMPETITION
AT A COMMERCIAL SHOOT...
April: ...FOR
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
Tyra: AND IN
THE LAST ELIMINATION,
CATIE WAS SENT HOME.
TONIGHT, CAN THE GIRLS
MASTER THEIR MOVES
WHEN THEY PERFORM
IN THE WORLD DEBUT
OF MY FIRST MUSIC VIDEO?
SIX GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE
ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
Camille: I'M NOT ELIMINATED.
I'M CONTINUING
ON THIS JOURNEY.
Tyra: WILL CATIE AND CAMILLE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
Camille: THERE'S DEFINITELY,
UM, INSECURITY.
Tyra: CAMILLE,
CONGRATULATIONS.
Mercedes: IT'S DOWN
TO SIX GIRLS, AND IT'S SARA,
ME, YOANNA, SHANDI,
CAMILLE AND APRIL.
Yoanna: CATIE BEING
ELIMINATED JUST GOES TO SHOW ME
THAT THE TABLES CAN TURN
ANYTIME DURING THIS COMPETITION.
I REALLY THOUGHT THAT CATIE
HAD WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE A TOP MODEL.
Camille: I'VE CHANGED.
I'VE MADE AN EFFORT
TO NOT TALK OVER PEOPLE.
ALL I CAN DO IS BE ME--
IS BE ME 100%.
♪♪♪
(phone beeps)
Shandi: HELLO?
Eric: Hey.
Shandi: HI, BABY.
Eric: How are you doing?
Shandi: GOOD.
Eric: Good.
Shandi: I'M WEARING
YOUR DRESS THAT YOU GAVE ME.
Eric: What did you say?
Shandi: I'M WEARING
YOUR DRESS.
Eric: You mean the, um...
Shandi: THE ONE YOU BOUGHT ME
FOR MY BIRTHDAY.
Eric: Yay! Really?
Shandi: MM-HMM.
MY BOYFRIEND ERIC AND I
HAVE BEEN DATING
ALMOST TWO YEARS.
HE IS SERIOUSLY, LIKE,
MY BEST FRIEND.
I LOVE YOU.
Eric: I love you, too.
Bye-bye.
♪♪♪
Yoanna: IT'S SARA'S BIRTHDAY,
AND I THINK IT'S SAD, YOU KNOW,
BEING AWAY FROM YOUR OWN HOME
AND NOT HAVING A CAKE.
DO THEY GIVE CANDLES?
Woman: MM-HMM.
Yoanna: THANK YOU.
AND PLUS I WANTED SOME CAKE,
TOO, SO... (laughs)
WHOO!
Women: (clapping)
Sara: THIS IS, LIKE,
THE BEST BIRTHDAY EVER.
IT REALLY IS.
Shandi: AW.
Sara: I'VE ALWAYS TAKEN
THE SAFE ROUTE.
I'VE ALWAYS QUIT THE JOBS
THAT INTIMIDATED ME,
AND EVEN THOUGH I'VE BEEN
LIKE THAT IN MY LIFE,
KIND OF TAKEN THE SAFE WAY,
I HAVE SO MUCH STRENGTH IN ME,
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY
I WANTED THIS SO BADLY--
BECAUSE I KNOW I CAN DO IT.
I WOULD LOVE TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
WANTS THIS AS BADLY AS I DO.
♪♪♪
Yoanna: I REALLY HAVE
A PASSION FOR THIS.
THIS IS SOMETHING
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED
SINCE I WAS A LITTLE GIRL.
I WANT IT SO BAD,
SO I'M GONNA MAKE SURE
THAT I, LIKE, PUT THAT OUT
IN THE UNIVERSE.
SO IF YOU HAD A CHOICE
TO BE AN ACTRESS OR A MODEL,
WHAT WOULD YOU CHOOSE,
LIKE, RIGHT NOW?
April: I VIEW
MODELING AS ACTING.
I VIEW MODELING
AS THE BASE OF ACTING.
THIS IS MY FIRST
MODELING EXPERIENCE EVER.
I'VE BEEN TOLD BY ENOUGH PEOPLE
THAT YES, YOU CAN BE A MODEL,
AND I HAVE TO RAISE THE BAR
ON MYSELF IF I WANT
TO WIN THIS THING,
BUT I THINK I CAN
IF I TRY REALLY HARD.
I'VE NEVER BEEN
IN EITHER SITUATION,
SO, LIKE, I REALLY--
IT'S TOO EARLY FOR ME TO SAY.
Yoanna: RIGHT.
IT'S ALMOST AS IF--
WELL, IS IT JUST THE GOAL
THAT SHE WANTS TO WIN,
OR IS SHE REALLY PASSIONATE
ABOUT BEING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T GIVE A DAMN
ABOUT FASHION
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
PERSONALLY, FOR ME,
IF APRIL WERE TO WIN
THE COMPETITION,
I WOULD BE DEVASTATED.
SO WHAT'S YOUR GOAL
RIGHT NOW?
April: TO WIN THIS CONTEST.
♪♪♪
Yoanna: TYRA MAIL!
Sara: WE GET TYRA MAIL,
AND IT SAYS THAT YOU GUYS
ARE GONNA NEED A LOT
OF ENERGY TODAY.
WE WALK INTO THIS BUILDING.
IT'S A DANCE STUDIO.
Mercedes: OH,
WE'RE GONNA BE DANCING!
LATIN! I CAN'T WAIT. OH!
I TURNED TO SHANDI,
AND SHE'S, LIKE, "OH, GOD.
I--I HOPE IT'S NOT THIS."
Tony: WHAT'S UP, LADIES?
Camille: HI.
Tony: COME ON IN.
I'M TONY MICHAELS.
I'M A CHOREOGRAPHER.
I'VE WORKED WITH J. LO.
I'VE WORKED WITH
CELINE DION.
I'VE WORKED WITH PRINCE.
I'VE WORKED WITH--
IT JUST GOES--
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
Shandi: AT FIRST, WALKING IN,
I WAS, LIKE, "HOW DOES DANCING,
YOU KNOW,
KIND OF GO INTO MODELING?"
Tony: TODAY I'M HERE
TO TEACH YOU GUYS
ALL ABOUT MOVEMENT.
DANCERS AND MODELS--
WE HAVE SO MUCH IN COMMON.
OUR BODIES ARE OUR INSTRUMENTS.
Shandi: I'VE NEVER ACTUALLY
TAKEN ANY DANCING CLASSES.
I MAY NOT DO THE BEST,
BUT I KNOW
I'M GONNA HAVE FUN WITH IT.
Tony: A PHOTOGRAPHER
AND A DESIGNER, THEY DO NOT WANT
TO BOOK YOU GUYS FOR A JOB,
AND YOU GUYS COME ON THE JOB,
AND THEY HAVE
TO TELL YOU HOW TO MOVE
AND HOW TO POSITION YOURSELVES
AND ALL THAT.
THAT SHOULD COME NATURAL.
Sara: OH, CRAP.
I KNOW MY KNEE IS A FACTOR.
I'VE HAD OPERATIONS ON MY KNEE
SO I COULD RUN AGAIN.
Tony: I WANT EACH ONE
OF YOU GUYS TO COME OUT,
AND I WANT YOU TO DANCE SEXY.
YOU'RE FIRST.
♪♪♪
Tony: YOUR EYES
WERE COMPLETELY ON THE FLOOR.
NO MATTER WHAT YOU DID,
YOUR EYES WERE COMPLETELY DOWN.
SO I--I AIN'T GETTING
NOTHIN' OUT OF YOU.
Sara: ALL RIGHT.
Tony: ALL OF THIS,
ALL OF THAT, IT WAS NOTHING
WITHOUT YOU LOOKING UP.
LET EVERYTHING MOVE TOGETHER,
CAMILLE.
Yoanna: CAMILLE--
I DON'T KNOW WHAT
SHE WAS TRYING TO DO,
BUT IT WAS INTERESTING.
Tony: SENSUAL.
TAKE YOUR TIME. TAKE YOUR TIME.
CATCH THE BEAT.
Mercedes: YOANNA'S DANCING
FITS HER CHARACTER.
IT'S, LIKE, KOOKY AND CRAZY
AND... (giggles) IT'S DIFFERENT.
Tony: SHANDI--
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HER,
YOU DON'T THINK TOP MODEL
RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
BUT ABOUT A SECOND GLANCE,
YOU SEE, "WOW. SHE'S GOT IT."
Yoanna: I'M SURPRISED
TO SEE SHANDI MOVE SO WELL,
'CAUSE I'D NEVER REALLY
SEEN HER DANCE BEFORE.
SHE'S BREAKING HER SHELL.
Tony: DON'T TRY
TO DANCE SEXY.
BE SEXY.
I'M THE MALE MODEL, OKAY?
I WANT YOU TO WORK AROUND ME.
YOU'RE FIRST.
♪♪♪
Shandi: APRIL'S DRIVE--
IT IS A LITTLE INTIMIDATING
JUST THINKING THAT THERE'S
SOMEBODY ELSE HERE THAT MAYBE
COULD POSSIBLY WANT IT
MORE THAN ME.
Mercedes: WE HAD TO, LIKE,
DANCE AROUND HIM,
USE HIM AS, LIKE,
IF WE WERE IN A PHOTO SHOOT.
♪ WHOA ♪
Tony: SHE'S THE FIRST PERSON
THAT DID LEVELS.
SHANDI IS PASSING EVERY TEST.
Mercedes: SHANDI IS, LIKE,
THAT DORK, NERDY TYPE OF GIRL,
BUT SHANDI IS DOING THE BEST.
SHE'S JUST FLOWING
VERY NATURALLY,
LIKE WHEN YOU DANCE.
Tony: TOUCHING. HOLDING.
UNH. UNH. UNH. UNH.
MOVE WITH YOUR EYES.
I AIN'T SEEN NOBODY TALK--
TYRA TALKS WITH HER EYES
ALL THE TIME.
TOMORROW YOU'RE GONNA COME BACK,
AND I'M GONNA TEST YOU
ON YOUR ABILITY TO MOVE.
Shandi: NO, I DON'T THINK
OF MYSELF AS SEXY.
I WAS TOLD REPEATEDLY, YOU KNOW,
"YOU'RE NEVER GONNA GET MARRIED.
YOU'RE JUST GONNA BE
THIS OLD SPINSTER
WITH A BUNCH OF CATS."
HOW COULD
I THINK THAT I'M SEXY?
♪♪♪
Shandi: I GOT SOMETHIN'.
Mercedes: YOU GOT SOMETHIN'?
Shandi: (laughing)
WHEN I GET THE PACKAGE
FROM MY BOYFRIEND, IT'S--
I HAD, LIKE,
A PIECE OF HOME WITH ME.
I HAVE A PIECE OF MY BOYFRIEND.
OH, HE DID HIS FACE.
HE DID HIS MODEL FACE.
Mercedes: OH, THAT'S GOOD.
THAT'S SO "ZOOLANDER"
RIGHT THERE.
Shandi: I JUST FEEL,
LIKE, REALLY LOVED
WHEN I OPENED IT UP.
HE SAID, LIKE, "ARE YOU GONNA
BE ON A SHOW CALLED
'WHO WANTS TO HOOK UP
WITH A WALGREEN EMPLOYEE?'"
Sara's mom: I'll give you
a pep talk.
What's going on?
Sara: MY KNEE WENT OUT
ON ME AGAIN.
I'M TRYING TO GET A HEAT PACK...
Sara's mom: Uh-huh.
Sara: TO THE POINT
WHERE I COULD--
Sara's mom: Is there a doctor
there to kind of watch--
Sara: I DIDN'T EVEN
ASK FOR ONE.
I WAS JUST, LIKE,
"I DON'T WANT TO DEAL WITH IT."
Sara's mom: How does
it feel today?
Sara: IT'S OKAY.
IT'S JUST REALLY SORE.
Sara's mom: Oh, honey...
Sara: MY KNEE
IS ALWAYS A DISCOMFORT.
ON A SCALE OF ONE TO TEN,
IT'S ABOUT A FOUR.
I'VE JUST LEARNED
TO LIVE WITH IT.
IT'S JUST REALLY HARD.
Shandi: I MISS MY BOYFRIEND.
I DO. I WISH--I REALLY WISH
HE COULD HAVE EXPERIENCED THIS
WITH ME, EVEN THOUGH I KNOW
HE WOULDN'T EXPERIENCE IT
THE SAME WAY.
(phone dialing)
(phone ringing)
Shandi: HELLO.
Eric: Do you remember
a girl named Lauren and...
Shandi: OH, YOU HUNG OUT
WITH SOME GIRLS?
Eric: They're, uh,
friends of Mike,
but I knew Lauren and Megan
about three years ago,
before I knew you.
They're good people,
and I'm gonna go
see a movie tonight.
I'm going with Lauren because
her husband works at AMC.
He's, like, a general manager,
and so she's getting us
free tickets.
Shandi: OH, THAT'S GREAT.
Eric: (laughing)
Honey, she has a kid
and a husband!
Shandi: OH, SO PEOPLE
NEVER CHEAT ON THEIR HUSBANDS?
Eric: No, they don't!
Shandi: EVEN IF THEY
HAVE KIDS?
Eric: No, they don't!
Shandi: YES, THEY DO.
YOU KNOW WHY THAT HURTS ME?
BECAUSE YOU'RE DOING SOMETHING
WITH SOMEONE THAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ME AND YOU.
Eric: I can't go
to the movies now?
Shandi: NO! I HATE YOU.
Eric: I didn't--
I didn't know that!
You didn't say that.
You didn't say, "Don't"--
Shandi: I SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO SAY THAT.
Eric: And I'm gonna go see
a movie tonight.
I'm going with Lauren.
Shandi: OH, THAT'S GREAT.
Eric: I can't go
to the movies now?
Shandi: NO!
MY BOYFRIEND PRETTY MUCH
PISSED ME OFF.
I HATE YOU.
Eric: I didn't know that!
Shandi: GOING TO THE MOVIES--
THAT'S, LIKE, OUR SACRED THING
THAT WE SHARE.
IT REALLY HURT
WHEN HE SAID THAT.
YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST, LIKE,
"HOW COULD YOU DO THAT?"
LIKE, I TRIED TO REMIND MYSELF
THAT I'M IN NEW YORK.
I'M GONNA HAVE A GOOD TIME.
I DON'T CARE.
♪♪♪
Shandi: ME, SARA, CAMILLE
AND MERCEDES ARE GOING TO A CLUB
TONIGHT CALLED THE SHOW.
Mercedes: NOW, SHANDI,
SHOW US WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT.
UH-OH!
THERE IT IS.
♪♪♪
Shandi: EVERY TIME I GO OUT,
I DON'T EXPECT
ANYONE TO TALK TO ME.
ALL OF A SUDDEN,
THERE'S THIS BOY
STANDING NEXT TO ME,
AND HE'S, LIKE, DANCING.
HE SAYS, "I JUST WANT
TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT YOU FOUR GIRLS
ARE THE HOTTEST GIRLS IN HERE."
I'M, LIKE, "OH, THANK YOU.
THAT'S SO NICE."
Mercedes: THEY HIT IT OFF,
AND IT WAS JUST FUN
'CAUSE SHANDI WAS, LIKE,
"IT WAS NICE TO MEET
SOMEONE REAL," SHE SAID.
Shandi: HE KEPT ASKING ME,
YOU KNOW, "DO YOU HAVE
A PHONE NUMBER?
IS THERE ANY WAY
I CAN CONTACT YOU?"
AND I KEPT SAYING, "NO."
HE JUST WAS LIKE--
HE WAS REALLY PERSISTENT.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT TO THINK.
I'M JUST, LIKE... OKAY.
♪ WHOA ♪
♪ WHOA ♪♪
Tony: 'SUP, LADIES?
Camille: 'SUP?
Mercedes: HEY.
Tony: WELCOME BACK.
YESTERDAY I TAUGHT YOU GUYS
ALL ABOUT MOVEMENT.
YOUR BODY IS YOUR INSTRUMENT,
AND YOU NEED TO KNOW
EVERYTHING ABOUT YOUR BODY.
YOU NEED TO BE COMFORTABLE
WITH IT.
TODAY YOU'RE GONNA
BE TESTED ON IT.
WHEN YOU GET
TO DO A RUNWAY SHOW,
THAT'S CHOREOGRAPHY.
April: WHEN WE FIRST
WALKED IN TODAY,
I DIDN'T GET A GOOD VIBE.
Tony: BEFORE I START
THE MUSIC, I WENT HOME, AND I,
YOU KNOW, I STARTED THINKING,
AND I STARTED GOING THROUGH
EACH INDIVIDUAL GIRL,
AND ONE THING
THAT KIND OF FELL ON ME
WAS THAT I HAD FORGOT
ALL ABOUT APRIL.
WHAT ABOUT APRIL?
IT DIDN'T STAND OUT.
THAT'S SOMETHING FOR YOU
TO THINK ABOUT,
FOR YOU TO LOCK IN.
YOU'VE GOTTA STEP UP YOUR GAME.
April: IT WAS, LIKE,
TAKING A HOT KNIFE
AND JUST JAMMING IT
ON INTO MY HEART.
THAT IS NOT GOOD.
THAT'S THE LAST THING
I WANT TO HEAR.
Tony: I PUT TWO TO THREE
8-COUNTS OF CHOREOGRAPHY
TOGETHER.
I'M GONNA TEACH IT TO YOU.
YOU'LL LEARN IT.
WE'LL PRACTICE IT,
THEN YOU'LL BE TESTED ON IT.
AND WHOEVER DOES THE BEST
WILL GET TO HANG OUT
WITH TWO MUSIC CELEBRITIES--
HUGE.
1.
SIT ON THIS HIP. THERE YOU GO.
3--YOU ROLL DOWN WITH IT.
POP THE HEAD UP--4.
OKAY, SARA, PUT YOUR WEIGHT--
LOOK AT MY LEGS.
Sara: THIS IS, LIKE,
MY BAD KNEE, THAT'S WHY.
Tony: YOU GOT A--
WHICH KNEE IS BAD?
Sara: OKAY,
MY KNEE LITERALLY HURTS.
IT'S KILLING ME RIGHT NOW.
Tony: 5... 6... 7... 8.
SIT UP, APRIL.
ALL RIGHT? HERE WE GO.
THE COMPETITION STARTS.
IF I TAP YOU,
YOU'RE GONNA LOSE THIS.
I WANT YOU TO COME OVER HERE
AND STAND IN A LINE.
EVERYBODY NEEDS
TO STEP THEIR GAME UP.
Tony: 5, 6, 7, 8.
♪♪♪
April: AS SOON AS IT WAS TIME
FOR ALL OF US TO BE OUT THERE,
I JUST WANTED TO FEEL ELECTRIC,
AND I WANTED TO BE ELECTRIC
TO HIM AND JUST SPARK FOR HIM.
Tony: SARA'S SEXUAL TO ME,
AND SHE JUST OOZES THAT,
BUT IT'S MORE LIKE
A SWIMSUIT TYPE OF MODEL
OR A CALENDAR TYPE OF MODEL.
SARA, STEP OFF.
Sara: I'M SICK OF LOSING.
I'M SICK OF IT.
I DON'T WANT TO LOSE ANYMORE.
Tony: GO BACK.
TODAY SHANDI ALLOWED
THE FRUSTRATION AND THE PRESSURE
OF THE COMPETITION
TO REALLY GET TO HER.
Tony: SHANDI, STEP OFF.
Shandi: THE WHOLE BALL GAME
IS COMPLETELY CHANGED AROUND.
THE BEST FROM THE DAY BEFORE
DID, LIKE, MEDIOCRE.
IT'S JUST, LIKE,
A COMPLETE TURNAROUND.
Tony: MERCEDES, STEP OFF.
Mercedes: I SUCKED
BOTH TIMES.
I HAVEN'T SHOWN TONY
THE BEST OF MY ABILITY.
Camille: I'M HERE TO WIN.
LOOK AT WHO YOUR
COMPETITION IS.
LIKE, JUST DO THE DAMN THING.
Tony: AGAIN.
Yoanna: IT'S COMING DOWN
TO THE END, AND I KNOW THAT
APRIL, CAMILLE AND MYSELF
WERE TOGETHER.
I WANT TO PROVE
THAT I CAN STAY FOCUSED
AND BE REAL AND, UM,
REALLY SERIOUS ABOUT NOW
THAT WE'RE GETTING CLOSER
TO THE END OF THE COMPETITION.
6, 7, 8.
Tony: STEP TO THE SIDE,
YOANNA.
Yoanna: TONY TAPS
MY SHOULDER, AND I'M EMBARRASSED
THAT I WASN'T
STILL WITH THE GIRLS.
Tony: YOANNA--SHE CAN'T SEEM
TO FIND THE RHYTHM.
NOW WE'RE DOWN TO TWO.
CAMILLE HAS REALLY
STEPPED UP HER GAME.
SHE FEELS THAT COMPETITION.
APRIL EXECUTED
THE ROUTINE AMAZINGLY.
Tony: CAMILLE, YOU'RE OUT.
I'M SORRY. BOOM.
April: YOU BELIEVE ME NOW,
HUH?!
Tony: AH, Y'ALL ARE GREAT.
YOU REMEMBER ME NOW, YO.
Mercedes: SURPRISE,
SURPRISE.
APRIL WON THE CHALLENGE.
SHE'S MOST DEFINITELY A THREAT.
Tony: CONGRATULATIONS.
April: THANK YOU.
Tony: AND YOU GET TO PICK
TWO PEOPLE TO GO WITH YOU.
April: SARA AND SHANDI.
Tony: OKAY.
SO GUESS WHAT.
GUESS WHO YOU ALL
GOIN' OUT WITH.
YOU AND YOU AND YOU,
YOU'RE GOIN' OUT WITH ODB.
April: GOD.
UNH-UNH.
Tony: AND RZA
FROM THE WU-TANG CLAN.
AND Y'ALL KNOW ODB IS BANANAS!
April: OH, MY GOD.
Tony: BANANAS.
April: I WAS REALLY SCARED
TODAY THAT IF I DIDN'T DO WELL
IN THE COMPETITION TODAY
THAT MY TIME WOULD BE UP.
NOW THAT I WON THAT COMPETITION,
MY FEAR'S A LITTLE BIT SUBSIDED.
♪♪♪
Yoanna: MY IMPRESSION
OF APRIL IS THIS...
Mercedes: (laughing)
Yoanna: SHH, IT'S THE TRUTH.
SHE LOOKS CONSTIPATED.
HOLD ON.
Mercedes: WELL, THAT'S
'CAUSE SHE'S VERY BINDING.
APRIL OVERANALYZES STUFF,
LIKE, THAT'S ONE THING THAT
REALLY ANNOYS ME ABOUT THE GIRL.
SHE JUST IS SO OVERANALYTICAL.
April: SEE, I WANT TO
CONVEY SOME--LIKE A TONE,
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE I NEED ALL
THE OPPORTUNITIES TO CONVEY SOME
KIND OF PERSONALITY THAT I CAN.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
LIKE, IF THEY SEE IT
IN A PHOTOGRAPH...
Mercedes: PEOPLE--
THE JUDGES SAID THAT YOU
ACTUALLY DID EXCELLENT.
Yoanna: YEAH,
BUT THAT DOESN'T REALLY COUNT,
'CAUSE SOMETIMES PEOPLE
WHO REALLY DO REALLY WELL
ARE ACTUALLY ASKED TO LEAVE,
AND IT DOESN'T REALLY MATTER.
(babbling)
HA!
♪♪♪
Shandi: WELL, I HAVE
SOMETHING I GOTTA TELL YOU.
ANOTHER BOY DANCED WITH ME.
Eric: Did he touch your butt?
Shandi: HE TOUCHED MY HIP,
BUT I JUST WANTED
TO TELL YOU THAT.
Eric: No, no. Whatever.
because this is just dripping
with hypocrisy.
Shandi: I WOULD FEEL
REALLY... IF I DIDN'T CALL HIM.
I'M SORRY,
I JUST WOULD BECAUSE--
Eric: Okay, then call him
and say, you know,
"I have a boy--"
Obviously, you told him that.
Shandi: NO, I DIDN'T.
(phone clicks)
Shandi: HELLO?
(dial tone)
Shandi: APRIL WON
THE DANCE-OFF AND SHE CHOSE
ME AND SARA.
WE'RE GONNA GO HAVE DINNER
WITH OL' DIRTY BASTARD,
RZA AND KINETIC
FROM THE WU-TANG CLAN.
♪♪♪
RZA: YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
April: HELLO.
RZA: WHAT UP? WHAT UP?
ODB: WHAT'S UP, GIRLS?
RZA: WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
WHO'S APRIL, WHO'S APRIL?
April: RIGHT HERE.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
WELCOME TO OUR SEMI-HOUSE.
RZA: WHO ARE THE FRIENDS?
April: THIS IS MERCEDES.
RZA: WHAT'S UP, MERCEDES?
WHAT UP, PRETTY GIRL?
Mercedes: NICE TO MEET YOU.
Shandi: I'M SHANDI.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
RZA: NICE TO MEET YOU, TOO.
YO, WHOA.
April: THAT'S SARA.
Sara: HEY.
ODB: MY NAME'S DIRT McGIRT.
RZA: WE GOTTA GO TO WORK.
TAKE YOU ALL OUT ON THE TOWN,
NEW YORK STYLE, ALL RIGHT?
April: ALL RIGHT.
RZA: WU-TANG STYLE, THOUGH.
Shandi: I KNOW TONIGHT
I'M JUST GONNA HAVE, LIKE,
THE GREATEST TIME, BECAUSE I
LIKE TO TALK TO PEOPLE.
I LIKE TO MEET NEW PEOPLE.
MY BOYFRIEND ERIC--
I DON'T KNOW HOW
HE'S GONNA TAKE IT.
♪♪♪
Shandi: A "HUMMER LIMO."
PIMPED OUT AS HELL.
OH, MY GOD.
I RODE IN A HUMMER LIMO
WITH ODB.
Kinetic: YOU HAVE
A BOYFRIEND, THAT'S GOOD.
ODB: DON'T YOU KNOW THAT
A BOYFRIEND, THAT'S A NATURAL
HABITAT FOR US TO HAVE?
Shandi: (laughing)
Kinetic: YOU HEARD IT FIRST.
ODB: IS IT HOT IN HERE?
Sara: IT IS GETTING
KINDA HOT.
ODB: WHY DON'T WE TURN
ON THE AIR CONDITIONING, MAN?
I LIKE THE HOT.
THE HEAT MAKE THE WOMEN SWEAT.
Shandi: WE ALL WALKED INTO
THE FRENCH RESTAURANT,
REALLY NICE.
EACH GIRL HAD A MAN.
I HAD KINETIC.
WE HAVE OUR OWN LITTLE ROOM.
RZA: THIS IS
A MODEL'S SPECIAL MEAL HERE.
IT HAS 1 CALORIE,
A SINGLE GRAM OF FAT...
Shandi: THOSE BOYS ARE SILLY.
SILLY, SILLY, SILLY.
YOU GOT ODB IN THE CORNER
SAYING--I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT HE'S SAYING...
ODB: GET BACK!
GET BACK, I GOT
THE CHECK!
YO, MAN, I'M SORRY, MAN.
I'M SORRY.
Shandi: BUT IT'S FUNNY,
WHATEVER IT IS.
BUT THE PERSON I, LIKE,
HIT IT OFF WITH,
LIKE, IMMEDIATELY WAS KINETIC.
HE'S ONLY, LIKE, 23 YEARS OLD.
Kinetic: WHAT KINDA GUYS
YOU LIKE?
Shandi: THE ARTSY...
Kinetic: ARTSY?
Shandi: ARTSY GUYS, YEAH.
April: SHANDI AND HIM
WERE GETTIN' ALONG VERY WELL.
Shandi: KINETIC--
ME AND HIM--WE JUST CLICKED.
AND KINETIC'S LIKE--
HE JUST PUTS HIS ARM AROUND ME,
HE BRINGS ME TO HIM.
HE'S LIKE,
"OH, YOU'RE COLD."
HE'S LIKE, "HERE, COME HERE.
WE'LL CUDDLE."
SO WE CUDDLED.
IT WAS SO SWEET.
♪♪♪
Camille: WE GOT TYRA MAIL!
"TOP MODELS GOTTA
DO MORE THAN JUST POSE
AND STRUT THE RUNWAY.
SO COME ON
AND SHAKE YA BODY...
MY WAY."
Mercedes: TYRA MAIL SAYS
WE NEED TO BE UP
AND READY TO GO AT 7:00
TO SHAKE OUR BODIES.
WOW, YOU KNOW, IT JUST
KEEPS ON GETTING BETTER.
THIS IS GREAT.
♪♪♪
Jay: GOOD MORNING.
Mercedes: GOOD MORNING.
Sara: GOOD MORNING.
Jay: SO THIS WEEK YOU GUYS
LEARNED THAT BEING A MODEL
IS NOT JUST STANDING IN FRONT OF
A CAMERA AND STRIKING A POSE.
IT'S ABOUT MOVING
AND MOVEMENT, RIGHT?
AND WE'LL BE STYLING YOU
IN HARD TAIL FOREVER CLOTHING.
I HAVE THE HONOR AND PRIVILEGE
TO TELL YOU GIRLS SOME BIG NEWS.
TODAY, YOU WILL BE DANCING
IN A MUSIC VIDEO,
AND THE BEST PART IS
THE VIDEO IS FOR
THE DEBUT SINGLE
FROM OUR VERY OWN TYRA BANKS.
Camille: I'M JUST SO HAPPY
TO BE A PART OF THIS,
BECAUSE WE HAD NO IDEA.
WE HAD NO IDEA.
TYRA IS DOING EVERYTHING.
Jay: TYRA,
WILL YOU COME OUTSIDE?
Tyra: Y'ALL BE GONNA DOIN'
MY FIRST SONG, HEY!
EVERYBODY KNOWS ME AS A MODEL.
I MEAN, THAT'S WHAT I'VE BEEN
DOIN' FOR A REALLY LONG TIME.
BUT NOW I'M MOVING INTO
THE WORLD OF RECORDING ARTIST,
AND I'M NERVOUS.
I REALLY AM.
Kennedy: YOU READY
FOR A LONG DAY?
A REAL DAY, A REAL FILM SHOOT.
MOVING IMAGES--
NOWHERE TO HIDE.
Tyra: IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR THE GIRLS TO KNOW
HOW TO MOVE, TO BE CONSCIOUS
OF THEIR BODY.
Jay: SO LET'S GET READY.
SEE YA.
ALL RIGHT.
♪♪♪
Sara: I'M JAZZED.
THIS IS TYRA'S VIDEO.
THIS IS CRAZY.
WHATEVER HAPPENS,
I WAS IN TYRA'S VIDEO,
SO THAT'S COOL.
I LOVE IT.
♪♪♪
Man: PLAYBACK, PLEASE.
Tyra: ♪ I DON'T WANT TO ♪
♪ TAKE IT SLOW ♪
♪ MOVE YOUR BODY ♪
♪ LET ME KNOW ♪
♪ LET ME SEE YA ♪
♪ LOSE CONTROL... ♪
Shandi: TYRA
IS LIKE SUPERWOMAN.
SHE SINGS, SHE ACTS,
SHE MODELS, SHE DANCES.
IT'S CRAZY WATCHING TYRA.
Tyra: ♪ IF YOU MOVE
LIKE ME, PLAYA ♪
♪ AND IF YA CAN'T KEEP UP ♪
♪ WITH ME, I'LL PLAY YA ♪
♪ 'CAUSE WHEN IT COMES ♪
♪ TO THIS I DON'T PLAY, I ♪
♪ SHAKE MY BODY, BODY ♪♪
Man: CUT!
Mercedes: WE'RE GONNA WALK
DOWN THE RUNWAY AND, YOU KNOW,
DO OUR POSES,
AND I ALREADY GOT A COUPLE DOWN.
LIKE... DO SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
BUT, UM, I'M REALLY EXCITED.
Man: ROLL PLAYBACK.
Man #2: ROLL TAPE.
Man: AND ACTION, PLEASE!
Tyra: ♪ CAN'T FIGURE OUT
WHY Y'ALL SAID IT'S OVER ♪
♪ THE CLUB'S PACKED... ♪
April: I'VE GOTTA WORK
LIKE I WANT IT.
THAT'S WHAT I'M GONNA
TELL MYSELF
WHEN I GO OUT THERE TODAY.
IF I DON'T GIVE IT MY ALL,
I'M OUT OF HERE.
Tyra: ♪ SO COME
AND TELL ME ♪
♪ WHAT'S GOOD WITH YOU ♪
♪ I'M FEELIN' YOU... ♪
Jay: APRIL TRIED
TO KNOCK YOANNA OUT,
AND YOANNA'S JUST SERVING UP
LIKE A TRUE TOP MODEL.
Tyra: ♪ TELL ME
IF YOU CAN HANDLE ME ♪
♪ I DON'T WANT TO
TAKE IT SLOW ♪
♪ MOVE YOUR BODY
LET ME KNOW... ♪
Yoanna: I'M PISSED.
I WAS REALLY UPSET
THAT SHE DID THAT.
SHE SHOULD
NEVER TOUCH ME.
Tyra: ♪ LET ME SEE
WHAT YOU'RE WORKIN' WITH ♪
♪ PLAYA... ♪
Mercedes: I GOTTA STEP IT UP.
THAT'S THE REALITY.
Tyra: ♪ AND IF YOU CAN'T
KEEP UP WITH ME ♪
♪ I'LL PLAY YA, 'CAUSE WHEN
IT COMES TO THIS ♪
♪ I DON'T PLAY, I ♪
♪ SHAKE MY BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ MOVE MY BODY, BODY ♪
♪ SHAKE MY BODY... ♪♪
Man: CUT!
Sara: I THINK ALL OF US
ARE JUST A LITTLE WORRIED.
IT'S DOWN TO SIX NOW.
YOU HAVE TO TURN IT ON
WHEN THEY ASK YOU.
Kennedy: IT'S A HOUSE PARTY,
ALL RIGHT?
LISTEN, EVERYONE'S GONNA TAKE
THEIR TURN TO BUST A MOVE.
GIVE ME MORE THAN ONE LOOK.
AND YOU HAVE THAT ONE MOMENT
TO SHINE.
I WANNA GET THAT...
AND LOOK BACK
AT THE PARTY.
I'M GONNA BE TIGHT ON THIS.
Tyra: SINGING HAS BEEN
A PASSION OF MINE
FOR A LONG TIME.
FOR SIX YEARS, ON THE DOWN-LOW,
I'VE BEEN DUCKING
IN AND OUT OF STUDIOS,
CUTTING TRACKS.
IF YOU'RE NOT READY
TO SHOW THE WORLD
WHAT YOU'RE DOIN',
DON'T SAY NOTHIN'.
BUT NOW I'M READY.
HERE I AM.
♪ IT'S OVER, OVER ♪
♪ I'LL TAKE CONTROL
WHAT I'LL SHOW YA ♪
♪ SHAKE YA BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ MOVE YA BODY, BODY ♪
♪ SHAKE YA BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ ROCK YA BODY, BODY ♪
♪ I'M TRYIN' TO FREAK YOU
ON THE FLOOR ♪
♪ LET ME SEE
SHAKE YA BODY ♪
♪ TILL IT'S SORE ♪♪
Mercedes: YOU GOT
YOUR DANCERS,
YOU GOT EVERYBODY WATCHING.
YOU GOT THE DIRECTOR,
SO IT'S LIKE, YOU KNOW,
HIT OR MISS.
THIS IS THE ONLY TIME.
Tony: 5, 6, 7, 8.
BOOM, BOOM, BOOM, BOOM.
Shandi: IT'S CRAZY.
I CAN'T BE MESSING UP.
Man: PLAYBACK SCENE.
5, 6, 7, 8.
Tyra: ♪ CAN'T FIGURE OUT
WHY Y'ALL SAID IT'S OVER ♪
♪ THE CLUB'S PACKED
AND ABOUT TO FLOW OVER ♪
♪ AND THAT RATIO'S
GOOD ENOUGH FOR US ♪
♪ AND I SEE ONE
POSSIBLY FOR ME ♪
♪ SO COME AND TELL ME
WHAT'S GOOD WITH YOU... ♪
Kennedy: SARA--
I FEEL LIKE SHE'S THINKING
A LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH
AND NOT JUST LETTING IT HAPPEN.
Sara: I KINDA MESSED UP
TWICE, SO I WAS JUST KINDA LIKE,
"OH, CRAP," AND KIND OF
WALKED BACK TO MY PLACE.
AND WHAT CAN I DO? YOU KNOW?
Tyra: ♪ I DON'T WANT TO
TAKE IT SLOW ♪
♪ MOVE YOUR BODY... ♪
Kennedy: I WAS REALLY
IMPRESSED WITH CAMILLE TODAY.
SHE JUST HAS A PRESENCE.
Tyra: ♪ TO TAKE CONTROL
OF YA ♪
♪ SO LET ME SEE WHAT
YOU'RE WORKIN' WITH... ♪
FIND THE BEAT, YOANNA!
IT'S OKAY!
FIND THE BEAT, GIRL!
♪ AND IF YOU CAN'T KEEP UP
WITH ME, I'LL PLAY YA ♪
♪ 'CAUSE WHEN IT COMES
TO THIS, I DON'T PLAY, I ♪
♪ SHAKE MY BODY, BODY ♪
♪ MOVE MY BODY,
BODY... ♪
Shandi: YOANNA JUST FALLS
FLAT ON THE FLOOR, AND...
(laughing)
Yoanna: I COULDN'T REMEMBER
MY CHOREOGRAPHY,
AND IT WAS JUST
REALLY FRUSTRATING.
IN THE END, WHAT TRIPPED ME UP
WAS NOT FINDING THE RIGHT BEAT
OR THE COUNT TO THE MUSIC.
Tyra: ♪ STOP THE TALKIN'
IT'S TIME THAT I SHOW YA ♪
♪ I'M GETTIN' IT DOWN... ♪
Mercedes: I'M FEELING,
"OKAY, YOU SCREWED UP, GIRL,
YEP, YOU DID IT,
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU KEEP ON GOIN'."
Tyra: ♪ YOU GETTIN' CLOSE
TO ME... ♪
MERCEDES, WHERE'S
THE CHOREOGRAPHY, GIRL?
♪ LET ME SHOW YOU
IT'S NOT A GAME, PLAYA ♪
♪ I'LL HAVE YOU SINGIN'
DON'T WANNA BE A PLAYA ♪
♪ I'LL SAY TAKE IT DOWN... ♪
LOOSEN IT UP, APRIL!
LOOSEN IT UP!
♪ I DON'T WANT TO
TAKE IT SLOW ♪
♪ MOVE YOUR BODY... ♪
April: FOR ONCE IN MY LIFE,
I CAN HONESTLY SAY
THIS COMPETITION IS NOT JUST
ABOUT WINNING FOR ME.
IT'S HONESTLY SOMETHING
THAT MY HEART REALLY DESIRES.
Tyra: ♪ I NEED TO SEE IF
YOU MOVE LIKE REAL, PLAYA ♪
♪ AND IF YOU CAN'T KEEP UP
WITH ME I'LL... ♪♪
YOU GUYS DID IT!
IT'S A WRAP!
Shandi: IT WENT AWESOME.
I HAD SO MUCH FUN.
THIS DOES NOT FEEL LIKE A JOB
TO ME AT ALL.
♪♪♪
Yoanna: TYRA MAIL.
I'LL READ IT.
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY FIVE OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ON
WITH THE HOPE OF BECOMING...
April and Yoanna: "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL."
Yoanna: "ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED."
Sara: (groans)
THIS ELIMINATION IS PROBABLY
THE ONE I'M DREADING THE MOST.
I'M NERVOUS.
♪♪♪
Sara: OH, MY GOD.
I WANT THIS MORE THAN
ANY OF THESE GIRLS UP HERE.
I KNOW FOR A FACT I WANT THIS
MORE THAN THESE GIRLS UP HERE.
Camille: IF I COME IN HERE
THINKING THAT I'M GOING HOME
AND DOUBTING MYSELF,
THEN IT'S OVER.
I'VE ALREADY LOST.
Yoanna: I REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHO'S GOING HOME THIS WEEK.
IT'S ALWAYS SOMETHING NEW
THAT IS GETTING THROWN AT US,
SO WE HAVE TO DEFINITELY BE
MULTIDIMENSIONAL AS TOP MODELS.
April: THERE'S ONLY
THREE WEEKS LEFT.
I'M WORKING MY HARDEST,
BUT IT'S STILL NOT ENOUGH.
April's boyfriend: Right.
April: YOU KNOW?
Shandi: APRIL IS SO AFRAID
OF LOSING, THAT IT REALLY LOOKS
LIKE SHE'S MAKING HERSELF SICK.
SHE'S SO OVERANALYZING
EVERY LITTLE DETAIL.
AND I CAN'T EVEN SAY,
"WELL, WHATEVER.
I DIDN'T CARE ANYWAY.
I JUST WANTED TO WIN TO WIN,"
BECAUSE IT'S NOT TRUE ANYMORE.
LIKE, THIS IS MY DREAM NOW.
IT'S MY PASSION.
I WANT IT SO BAD, LIKE,
IT WOULD HURT SO MUCH
TO GET THIS CLOSE
AND, LIKE, SEE IT
AND ALMOST TOUCH IT
AND THEN HAVE THE DOOR
SLAMMED IN MY FACE.
Tyra: HELLO, EVERYBODY.
Women: HELLO.
Tyra: SO YOU GUYS HAD
A WHIRLWIND OF A WEEK, I KNOW.
YOU GOT TO SEE HOW
IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO MOVE
AND TO MOVE WELL TO BE A MODEL,
AND YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER
WE'RE EVALUATING YOU
ON EVERYTHING,
NOT JUST YOUR PERFORMANCE
IN THE VIDEO THIS WEEK,
BUT ON YOUR OVERALL LOOK, SKILL,
AND POTENTIAL TO BE A TOP MODEL.
BUT NOW IT'S TIME TO MAKE
OUR SEVENTH CUT TOWARDS
DETERMINING WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ALL RIGHT, AMONG THE PRIZES
THAT THE WINNER WILL RECEIVE
IS A CONTRACT WITH IMG MODELS,
A FASHION SPREAD
IN "JANE" MAGAZINE,
AND A COSMETICS CAMPAIGN
WITH SEPHORA.
SO NOW WE HAVE OUR PANEL
OF JUDGES.
FIRST, WE HAVE
MISS JANICE DICKINSON,
ONE OF THE FIRST SUPERMODELS
OF THE WORLD.
Janice: AND QUEEN
OF MOVEMENT.
(laughter)
Tyra: ERIC NICHOLSON.
ERIC IS
THE SENIOR FASHION EDITOR
OF "JANE" MAGAZINE.
MR. NIGEL BARKER.
NIGEL IS A NOTED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
OVER HERE, MR. TONY MICHAELS,
WHO'S MY CHOREOGRAPHER
THAT HAD TO WORK WITH YOU GUYS
AND SHOW YOU THE MOVES
THIS WEEK.
SO NOW WE'RE GONNA DO
YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
WE'VE RANDOMLY SELECTED NAMES,
AND, SHANDI, YOU'RE FIRST.
ALL RIGHT, SHANDI,
SO YOU HAD TO SHAKE YOUR THANG
IN MY VIDEO, AND THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE BEING JUDGED ON--
BY THE CHOREOGRAPHY
THAT TONY MICHAELS TAUGHT YOU.
HERE IS YOUR PART.
♪ CAN'T FIGURE OUT
WHY Y'ALL SAID IT'S OVER ♪
♪ THE CLUB'S PACKED
AND ABOUT TO FLOW OVER ♪
♪ AND THE RATIO'S
GOOD ENOUGH FOR US... ♪
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
WOULD EVER THINK THAT
SHANDI'S GOT THAT MUCH SOUL--
SHANDI THAT WORKS IN WALGREENS!
YOU WERE WORKIN' IT,
AND I WAS JUST LIKE,
"OH, MY GOD! SHE IS DOIN' THIS!"
Nigel: I ACTUALLY FOUND YOU
TODAY JUST RIGHT NOW
AS THE SEXIEST I'VE FOUND YOU.
Tyra: THANK YOU.
Eric: THANKS, SHANDI.
Tyra: ♪ COME AND TELL ME
WHAT'S GOOD WITH YOU ♪
♪ I'M FEELIN' YOU
ARE YOU FEELIN' ME? ♪
♪ I'M FEELIN' LIKE
I CAN DANCE ALL NIGHT ♪
♪ SO TELL ME
IF YOU CAN HANDLE ME... ♪
I FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE
A LOT OF FIRE INSIDE OF YOU,
BUT IT'S LIKE
YOU WERE HOLDING BACK.
LIKE, I SEE IT THERE,
AND I'M LIKE, "JUST TAKE IT!"
YOU KNOW, BUT YOU'D GO... AH.
Janice: YOU DIDN'T GIVE
ANY KINDA, LIKE, HEAT.
Tyra: THANK YOU.
♪ I DON'T WANT TO
TAKE IT SLOW ♪
♪ MOVE YOUR BODY
LET ME KNOW ♪
♪ LET ME SEE YOU LOSE CONTROL ♪
♪ LEAVE IT UP TO ME
TO TAKE CONTROL OF YA... ♪
Eric: YOU LOOKED GOOD,
BUT THEN YOU JUST SORT OF
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT SONG
YOU WERE DANCING TO.
Janice: IT WAS SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN A BAD MUSIC VIDEO
BACKUP DANCER AND, LIKE,
A BELLY DANCER
AT A GREEK RESTAURANT.
Tony: YOU NEVER JUST
COMMITTED TO "I'M GONNA STAY
THROUGH THE WHOLE THING."
Tyra: ♪ SHAKE MY BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ MOVE MY BODY, BODY ♪
♪ SHAKE MY BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ ROCK MY BODY, BODY ♪
♪ ONCE I GET STARTED
IT'S OVER ♪
♪ I CAN'T CONTROL
WHAT I SHOW YA... ♪
WHEN I WAS THERE,
I SAW YOU GROOVIN',
BUT I WAS LIKE,
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE STEPS?
Mercedes: WELL,
I WENT TO GO INTO IT, I'M LIKE,
"OH, CRAP! WHAT COMES NEXT?"
SO I'M LIKE,
YOU KNOW WHAT?
PLAY IT OFF,
GO ALL THE WAY THROUGH,
SO I DID.
Tony: IF THAT, YOU KNOW,
SOMEONE WAS REALLY ASKING YOU
TO DO THE CHOREOGRAPHY,
YOU WANNA COMPLETE IT.
FIND SOME WAY TO COMPLETE IT
BEFORE THAT MUSIC STOPS.
Tyra: ♪ STOP THE TALKIN'
IT'S TIME THAT I SHOW YA ♪
♪ HOW I'M GETTIN' IT DOWN
AND I KNOW YA ♪
♪ LIKE THE WAY THAT
MY BODY SHAKES FOR YA... ♪
Janice: I KEEP THINKING
THOSE MOVEMENTS LOOK LIKE
YOU HAVE AN UPSET STOMACH.
YOU LOOK LIKE, YOU KNOW,
YOU NEED TO GO
TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM.
Nigel: IT NEEDED MORE SOUL.
IT WAS ALMOST
TOO CLINICAL.
Tony: THAT WAS STRONG.
YOU REMEMBERED
ALL THE CHOREOGRAPHY.
Tyra: ♪ SHAKE MY BODY
BODY ♪
♪ MOVE MY BODY, BODY ♪
♪ SHAKE MY BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ ROCK MY BODY, BODY ♪
♪ ONCE I GET STARTED
IT'S OVER, OVER ♪
♪ I CAN'T CONTROL
WHAT I SHOW YA, BABY ♪
♪ SHAKE YA BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ MOVE YA BODY, BODY... ♪
Janice: WHAT THE HELL
WAS THAT?
YOU LOOK LIKE
A 1920s FLAPPER THERE,
LIKE FLAPPING.
Tony: I ALWAYS TOLD YOU
TO TAKE YOUR TIME,
FIND THE RHYTHM.
YOU DIDN'T TAKE YOUR TIME THERE,
AND SO YOU LOST ALL OF WHAT,
YOU KNOW, YOU LEARNED.
Tyra: YOU WERE, LIKE,
REALLY OFF BEAT,
THEN I LOOKED AT THE DANCERS
IN THE BACKGROUND,
AND THEY WERE DOING THIS,
AND YOU WERE ALL OVER THE PLACE.
Nigel: YOU WERE LACKING
THE SEX APPEAL.
YOU'RE GORGEOUS.
YOU'VE GOT A BEAUTIFUL FACE,
BUT YOU NEED TO OOZE
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
Tyra: OKAY, YOANNA, THANKS.
Eric: THANKS.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, YOU GUYS,
HERE'S SOME PHOTOS THAT WE TOOK
ON THE SET OF THE VIDEO.
Janice: MERCEDES--
WHEN SHE WAS DOING
HER--HER HOOCHIE DANCE.
SHE HAS CAPITAL I-T, THIS GIRL.
Nigel: MERCEDES
IS DEFINITELY IN.
Tyra: YOANNA.
Janice: I WAS STARING AT HER
BECAUSE SHE KEPT THROWING
HER ARMS UP AS OPPOSED
TO THE HIP-HOP THING.
Tyra: YOANNA FELL FLAT
ON HER BOOTY.
Nigel: YOANNA IS BEAUTIFUL.
SHE'S FIERCE.
HER EYES ARE STRONG.
YOU KNOW, FOR ME,
WHEN IT COMES
TO ANYTHING ACTUALLY IN MOTION,
IT DIDN'T REALLY WORK FOR ME.
I'M AFRAID FOR ME, YOANNA--
SHE'S OUT.
Tyra: SARA.
Janice: I DIDN'T SEE
ANY DANCE MOVEMENT.
I JUST SAW, YOU KNOW,
BELLY DANCING STRIPPER.
Tyra: I THINK THAT SARA IS
THE ONLY GIRL HERE THAT HAS
THAT SUPER TOP MODEL LOOK.
SHE CAN STAND RIGHT NEXT
TO ME AND HEIDI
IN A VICTORIA'S SECRET AD,
ALL OF US, AND FIT RIGHT IN.
Eric: SARA, FOR ME, I THINK
JUST IS STARTING--
I'M STARTING TO FEEL THAT
SHE COULD BE GOING
WAY DOWN MARKET,
LIKE THE BEER COMMERCIALS.
Tyra: APRIL.
Tony: EVERY CHALLENGE
THAT I GAVE HER,
SHE CLEANED IT RIGHT UP.
Nigel: BUT THE PROBLEM FOR ME
WITH APRIL IS THAT, YOU KNOW,
SHE'S CLINICAL.
SHE'S LIKE A TECHNICIAN.
I WANNA SEE
SOME MORE SEX APPEAL.
Tony: APRIL IS THE ONE
THAT WANTS IT THE MOST.
Nigel: WELL,
THEY ALL WANT IT.
I THINK THAT SHE--THEY ALL
WANT IT IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
Tony: MAYBE SHE HAS
THE DRIVE.
Janice: I WANT TO SEE
AN ASIAN GIRL WIN
THIS COMPETITION BECAUSE
SHE IS COMMERCIAL.
SHE IS EXOTIC.
Nigel: CAMILLE--
SHE WAS SEXY. SHE DANCED WELL.
SHE DID A GREAT JOB.
Janice: SHE DIDN'T HAVE
AN ATTITUDE, BUT IS THAT AN ACT?
Nigel: AND SHE SMILED.
Janice: IS THAT AN ACT?
Nigel: MAYBE,
BUT SHE'S LEARNING.
Janice: MAYBE IT'S LIKE
A MULTIPLE PERSONALITY,
LIKE, YOU KNOW, JEKYLL AND HYDE.
Nigel: SHANDI--
SHE'S FASCINATING.
SHE HAS A FACE FOR NOW
AND A FACE FOR THE FUTURE.
Tony: SHE DOESN'T TRY HARD.
SHE'S JUST--SHE'S DOING IT.
I COULDN'T TAKE MY EYES OFF HER
ON THIS VIDEO.
Janice: YOU GO, GIRL!
YOU GO, GIRL!
YOU GO! SHE'S IN!
♪♪♪
Tyra: I HAVE SIX
VERY BEAUTIFUL WOMEN
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME.
Tyra: BUT I ONLY HAVE
FIVE PHOTOS IN MY HANDS.
THESE FIVE PHOTOS WILL REPRESENT
THE FIVE OF YOU THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
I'M GOING TO CALL--SHANDI.
SHANDI, YOU DID THE CHOREOGRAPHY
IN THAT VIDEO BETTER THAN
EVERY SINGLE GIRL BEHIND YOU
COMBINED.
I WAS CHEERING YOU ON
LIKE I WAS YOUR MAMA,
LIKE YOUR PROUD MAMA THAT WAS
JUST LIKE, "THERE'S MY BABY.
I HAD NO IDEA."
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
MERCEDES.
CAMILLE.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME
I'M GOING TO CALL...
Tyra: IS APRIL.
WE'RE NOT SURE IF YOU WANT THIS
BECAUSE YOU WANNA BE A TOP MODEL
AND YOU WANNA BE
IN THIS FASHION INDUSTRY,
OR IS IT THAT YOU JUST WANT
TO WIN FOR THE SAKE OF WINNING?
CONGRATULATIONS.
April: THANK YOU.
Tyra: WILL YOANNA AND SARA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
Tyra: YOANNA, IN THE VIDEO,
YOU WERE SO ALL OVER THE PLACE
AND SO UNFOCUSED, AND SOMETIMES
YOU ONLY GET ONE CHANCE,
SO WHEN THE DIRECTOR SAYS,
"ACTION," YOU HAVE TO BE READY.
SARA...
OUT OF ALL THE GIRLS,
YOU ARE THE SEXIEST GIRL HERE,
SARA, BUT THE JUDGES ARE
STARTING TO WONDER,
IS YOUR SEXUALITY
THE TYPE OF SEXUALITY
THAT WILL ONLY BE GOOD
IN THE TOP MEN'S MAGAZINES
RIGHT NOW,
OR IS IT A SEXUALITY
THAT TRANSCENDS TO WOMEN,
WHERE YOU CAN ALSO BE
RIGHT AT HOME
IN A FASHION MAGAZINE?
THIS IS
THE HARDEST WEEK FOR ME.
AND IT'S HARD FOR ME BECAUSE
(voice breaking) I'M STARTING
SOMETHING NEW IN MY LIFE--
SOMETHING THAT I'M PUTTING
MYSELF OUT THERE FOR THE WORLD
TO PUT ME IN THE POSITION
THAT YOU ARE ALL IN NOW.
SO WHO AM I TO STAND HERE
AND TELL YOU
THAT YOU HAVE TO LEAVE
WHEN I'M STARTING SOMETHING
WHERE THE WHOLE WORLD
IS GONNA BE CRITICIZING ME?
AND I JUST WANNA THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING PART OF MY DREAM.
I ONLY HAVE ONE PICTURE
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PICTURE REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL CONTINUE ON
AND WILL STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Tyra: YOANNA,
CONGRATULATIONS.
Sara: (sobbing)
Mercedes: I LOVE YOU SO MUCH.
Tyra: I'M SORRY.
Sara: (continues sobbing)
THIS IS MY DREAM.
IT'S LIKE, THEY HAVE NO IDEA
I'M SO PROUD OF MYSELF.
I'VE DONE THINGS
THAT I'VE NEVER EVEN IMAGINED ME
DOING IN MY LIFE,
THINGS I'VE BEEN SCARED TO DO,
THINGS THAT I HAD TO BREAK
OUT OF MY SHELL TO DO,
AND THIS MADE ME DO THAT.
THIS IS NOT
GONNA STOP ME.
THIS WILL NOT STOP ME
FROM MAKING MY DREAM COME TRUE.
♪♪♪
Tyra: STAY TUNED
FOR THE WORLD PREMIERE
OF MY MUSIC VIDEO AND SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
Man: AND NOW
THE WORLD PREMIERE
OF "SHAKE YA BODY" IN...
♪♪♪
Tyra: COME HERE...
I SEE YOU
WATCHING ME...
AND I KNOW YOU WANNA...
Man: TYRA.
Tyra: YEAH,
I KNOW YOU WANNA DANCE.
♪ CAN'T FIGURE OUT
WHY Y'ALL SAID IT'S OVER ♪
♪ THE CLUB'S PACKED
AND ABOUT TO FLOW OVER ♪
♪ AND THE RATIO'S
GOOD ENOUGH FOR US ♪
♪ AND I SEE ONE POSSIBLY
FOR ME ♪
♪ SO COME AND TELL ME
WHAT'S GOOD WITH YOU ♪
♪ I'M FEELIN' YOU
ARE YOU FEELIN' ME? ♪
♪ I'M FEELIN' LIKE
I CAN DANCE ALL NIGHT ♪
♪ SO TELL ME
IF YOU CAN HANDLE ME ♪
♪ I DON'T WANT TO
TAKE IT SLOW ♪
♪ MOVE YOUR BODY,
LET ME KNOW ♪
♪ LET ME SEE
YOU LOSE CONTROL ♪
♪ LEAVE IT UP TO ME
TO TAKE CONTROL OF YA ♪
♪ SO LET ME SEE
WHAT YOU'RE WORKIN' WITH ♪
♪ PLAYA ♪
♪ I NEED TO SEE IF YOU MOVE
LIKE REAL, PLAYA ♪
♪ AND IF YOU CAN'T KEEP UP
WITH ME, I'LL PLAY YA ♪
♪ 'CAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
I DON'T PLAY, I ♪
♪ SHAKE MY BODY, BODY ♪
♪ MOVE MY BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ SHAKE MY BODY, BODY ♪
♪ ROCK MY BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ ONCE I GET STARTED
IT'S OVER ♪
♪ I CAN'T CONTROL
WHAT I SHOW YA ♪
♪ SHAKE YA BODY, BODY ♪
♪ MOVE YA BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ SHAKE YA BODY, BODY ♪
♪ ROCK YA BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ I'M TRYIN' TO FREAK YOU
ON THE FLOOR ♪
♪ DON'T STOP SHAKE
YA BODY TILL IT'S SORE ♪
♪ OH ♪
♪ COME ON, BABY ♪
♪ OH, OH, OH ♪
♪ STOP THE TALKIN'
IT'S TIME THAT I SHOW YA ♪
♪ HOW I'M GETTIN' IT DOWN
AND I KNOW YA, KNOW YA ♪
♪ LIKE THE WAY
THAT MY BODY SHAKES FOR YA ♪
♪ AND I SEE YOU
GETTIN' CLOSE TO ME ♪
♪ SO COME ON OVER
AND DO YOUR THING ♪
♪ PLAYA ♪
♪ LET ME SHOW YOU
IT'S NOT A GAME ♪
♪ PLAYA ♪
♪ I'LL HAVE YOU SINGIN'
DON'T WANNA BE A PLAYA ♪
♪ I'LL SAY TAKE IT DOWN
A NOTCH, PLAYA ♪
♪ I DON'T WANT TO
TAKE IT SLOW ♪
♪ MOVE YOUR BODY,
LET ME KNOW ♪
♪ LET ME SEE YA LOSE CONTROL
AND THEN I'LL JUST ♪
♪ TAKE CONTROL OF YA ♪
♪ SO LET ME SEE
WHAT YOU'RE WORKIN' WITH ♪
♪ PLAYA ♪
♪ I NEED TO SEE IF YOU MOVE
LIKE REAL, PLAYA ♪
♪ AND IF YOU CAN'T KEEP UP
WITH ME, I'LL PLAY YA ♪
♪ 'CAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
I DON'T PLAY, I ♪
♪ SHAKE MY BODY, BODY ♪
♪ MOVE MY BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ SHAKE MY BODY, BODY ♪
♪ ROCK MY BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ ONCE I GET STARTED
IT'S OVER, OVER ♪
♪ I CAN'T CONTROL
WHAT I SHOW YA, BABY ♪
♪ SHAKE YA BODY, BODY ♪
♪ MOVE YA BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ SHAKE YA BODY, BODY ♪
♪ ROCK YA BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ I'M TRYIN' TO FREAK YOU
ON THE FLOOR ♪
♪ DON'T STOP SHAKE YA BODY
TILL IT'S SORE ♪
♪ OH, OH, OH ♪
♪ COME ON, BABY ♪
♪ LET ME SAY THIS ♪
♪ YOUR BODY'S
CALLIN' ME ♪
♪ I CAN HEAR IT SPEAK ♪
♪ OOH ♪
♪ SO LET ME PLEASE YOU ♪
♪ AH, AH, AH ♪
♪ JUST GRAB
MY HIPS REAL TIGHT ♪
♪ AND ENJOY THE RIDE ♪
♪ OH, IT'S UP TO YOU ♪
♪ MY BABY ♪
♪ TO MAKE ME
FEEL THE HEAT ♪
♪ AND LET ME KNOW
IF YOU CAN KEEP UP WITH ME ♪
♪ SHAKE MY BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ MOVE MY BODY, BODY ♪
♪ SHAKE MY BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ MOVE MY BODY, BODY ♪
♪ ONCE I GET
STARTED IT'S OVER, OVER ♪
♪ I CAN'T CONTROL
WHAT I SHOW YA ♪
♪ SHAKE YA BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ MOVE YA BODY, BODY ♪
♪ SHAKE YA BODY,
BODY ♪
♪ ROCK YA BODY, BODY
OOH ♪
♪ I'M TRYIN' TO FREAK YOU
ON THE FLOOR ♪
♪ LET ME SEE
DON'T STOP ♪
♪ SHAKE YA BODY
TILL IT'S SORE ♪
Man: ♪ UHH ♪
♪ I KNOW YOU
WANNA SHAKE YA BODY ♪
♪ TYRA, I KNOW YOU
♪ UHH, OH, TYRA, JUST
UHH, TYRA, SHAKE IT ♪
♪ UHH, COME ON, TYRA, I WANNA
SHAKE YA, SHAKE YA ♪
♪ I WANNA SHAKE YA BODY ♪♪
Tyra: HERE'S
WHAT COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
THE GIRLS TAKE
A EUROPEAN FASHION CAPITAL
BY STORM,
BUT SHANDI'S GLAMOROUS
NEW LIFESTYLE
WORRIES HER BOYFRIEND...
Shandi: MY LIFE HAS, LIKE,
COMPLETELY CHANGED.
Tyra: WHERE
YOANNA'S DEEPEST INSECURITIES
COME UNDER FIRE...
YOU HAVE TO
WORK ON YOUR BODY.
AND CAMILLE PUSHES
A CONTROVERSIAL SITUATION
TOO FAR.
Yoanna: WHAT DID YOU
JUST SAY?
YOU SAID IT
IN FRONT OF TYRA BANKS.
YOU SHUT UP.
♪♪♪